GO, I KNOW THAT RAY ALLEN AND
REGGIE MILLER ARE OVER THERE
BEHIND YOU, AND WHAT DO THEY
HAVE COOKED UP FOR YOU -- CAN
YOU BRING THEM IN?
>> THEY GOT THEIR JERSEYS RIGHT
HERE, OBVIOUSLY, AND WHAT IS
THAT?
>> COME ON IN HERE.
LET'S SEE THIS.
SO THIS IS -- THIS IS PRETTY
SPECIAL, MAN.
>> THIS IS WHAT IS IT ABOUT.
>> I HAVE BEEN THINKING THE
ABOUT THIS NUMBER FOR A LONG
TIME, AND I HAVE IT ON MY SHOE,
AND BASKETBALL HISTORY, AND THIS
IS PRETTY SPECIAL.
I MEAN, LIKE I SAID, THESE TWO
LEGENDS.
AND I WATCHED THEM GROWING UP,
AND UNDERSTOOD WHAT IT MEANT TO
SHOOT THE BALL BECAUSE OF THEM
AND MY DAD, AND FULL CIRCLE
MOMENT, AND I'M BLESSED.
BLESSED FOR SURE.
>> IT WAS A SPECIAL NIGHT, AND
PROUD TO BE WITNESSES TO IT, AND
NICE GOING, STEPHEN, AND YOU ARE
AT THE TOP OF THE MOUNTAIN.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, MY FAVORITE
PLAYER.
>> HE MAKES IT LOOK
STEPH-ERTLESS.
>> A FABULOUS NIGHT, AND GREAT
EFFORT, AND TO SEE THOSE GUYS
CELEBRATING WITH HIM, IT IS SUCH
A HONOR.
>> AND TO HEAR REGGIE SAY THAT
HE IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
SHOOTER OF ALL TIME, AND I'M
PETTY, AND I WOULD HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT, BUT STEPH IS
ONE OF MY FAVORITE PLAYER,
BECAUSE I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYBODY SHOOT AT THE MAGNITUDE
THAT HE DOES.
I AM HAPPY FOR STEPH AND HIS
FAMILY AND HAPPY FOR THOSE GUYS,
AND IT CAN ONLY HAPPEN HERE ON
TNT.
>> GAME REOGNIZES GAME, RIGHT,
KENNY?
>> YES, HE IS THE BEST SHOOTER
BECAUSE OF THIS.
HE CAN DO IT ON THE CATCH AND
SHOOT, AND HE CAN DO IT ON THE
DOWN SCREEN FOR A PICK, AND OFF
OF THE DRIBBLE.
IF YOU A